Comment vont mes petits "zouzous" en vacances là hein ?
Le mec qui se prend pour un animateur de colonie
Les amis j'fais cette vidéo parce que
Cette année, ces 365 derniers jours sur YouTube ont été les plus oufs de ces 6 dernières années
J'ai envie de revenir avec vous sur les ... les moments qui m'ont vraiment marqué cette année qui ... qui m'ont vraiment fait extrêmement plaisir
Et qui seront des souvenirs inoubliables tout simplement pour la plupart
J'aimerai simplement vous en dire plus sur ces moments là
Vous dire pourquoi c'était si important à mes yeux et
Et pourquoi c'était vraiment heu... génial
Et encore une fois merci parce que
Vraiment je me suis jamais autant amusé sur YouTube
C'est complètement ouf grâce à vous
Je vis de..de..de ça, je peux faire c'que j'veux
Sur ma chaîne j'me suis pas enfermé dans un type de vidéo
Vous êtes super ouverts à..aux vidéos que je fais
Et des fois je fais des trucs qui sont un peu des O.V.N.I. ( On m'apelle l'OVNI)
Et qui sont différents et vous appréciez
Et vous même vous me donnez du courage
En fait vous dîtes : "Pu**** c'est cool ça change !"
Tu peux en refaire c'est sympa
voilà
J'ai cette chance, c'est pas tout le monde qui a cette chance sur YouTube
Donc vraiment merci beaucoup
Ca fais maintenant 1 an et 2 mois que j'ai un studio
Et je suis arrivé là-dedans juste avant 🎮 l' E3 2016 🎮
Avec lequel on était allé avec Cyprien, Jimmy etc...
Je suis arrivé j'ai fais des petites photos dedans. Y avait pas de mousses isolantes ici
J'étais tout content, j'étais comme un gamin
Et BIM je me suis barré à Los Angeles pour l'E3
Donc j'étais encore plus content
Cyprien : M'accorderiez vous cette dance ?
Squeezie : Mais avec joie
Je suis rentré de l'E3 il faisait beau tout ça
On faisait des vidéos gaming comme d'habitude
Des compliations, des p'tits jeux NAWAK, des petits quizzs tout ça
Et puis !
Pokémon go arrive !
Les yeux collés à leur smartphone
Les joueurs marchent visages baissés
Vous allez tout nous dire sur ce jeu "Pokémon Go"
Qui s'est répandu depuis le début de l'été
Comme une traînée de poudre à travers le monde
Ça n'existait qu'au Japon et aux Etats-Unis
Mais voilà, les Pokémons débarquent à Paris
Le buzz est colossal
Tout l'monde en parle, tout les médias reprennent ça
Et on se dit, avec Clément, qui m'aide à cadrer et à monter les vidéos
Euh... Bon, on va peut-être faire un truc, hein ?
Sur Pokémon Go, mais pas un truc de m****
Faut faire un truc vraiment marrant !
Et on se dit "Vas-y on va partir dans la rue jouer un personnage,
un chasseur complètement égocentrique
et qui est sûr de lui, qui se la pète, qui est insolent !"
On décide alors de faire cette première vidéo un petit peu à l'arrache,
tellement à l'arrache qu'on se fait choper par la DGSE à la fin
Et là on met ça en ligne, et c'était le début des vidéos un peu différentes
où on osait aller dehors, on osait sortir du bureau
et ça vous a extrêmement plus !
Et j'en garde un souvenir mémorable parce que
Ca m'avait vraiment fait chaud au coeur !
Et ça m'avait donné beaucoup d'envie pour tout ce qui allait suivre !
Aussitôt la vidéo sortie, aussitôt je dis à Clément
"P*tain mec, il faut qu'on remette ça c'était trop marrant
en plus on va dehors, on sort un peu du studio, c'est vraiment cool
et ça a l'air... ça plaît énormément aux gens !"
Et j'me dis "Vas-y on va passer à l'étape du dessus
on va faire ça dans un véhicule électrique"
on sort la vidéo avec le véhicule électrique, vous adorez,
j'me dis "Bon bah là, y'a plus qu'à gérer les pokémons eau
et... puis les pokémons air on pourra pas
parce qu'un hélicoptère euh... c'est chaud !
Bref, c'était des vidéos qui m'ont vraiment fait plaisir à faire
et qui ont marqué je trouve un petit peu, ce nouveau départ
il y a 1 an...
Même vous, c'est ce que vous me disiez et...
et c'est vrai, maintenant je m'en rend compte
C'était vraiment chouette !
Un mois plus tard, je décide de rejoindre mon frère en Colombie
qui était, lui, en road-trip avec sa copine depuis 7 mois.
Il rentrait en septembre et sa copine voulait absolument qu'on lui fasse la surprise
que je vienne sans rien lui dire...
Bon, en vrai il avait un petit peu grillé mais quand même, il était surpris,
ça a quand même marché !
Je décide alors de faire 2/3 vidéos d'avance et de me dire
"Vas-y, il sera en road-trip pendant 7 mois qu'une seule fois dans sa vie,
j'aurais l'occasion de le surprendre comme ça qu'une seule fois dans ma vie,
alors c'est parti !
Et ce voyage m'a beaucoup rapproché de mon frère,
et c'est en partie grâce à vous, parce qu'aller en Colombie,
ça coûte des thunes
hein, l'avion, le séjour... tout ça, ça coûte de l'argent,
et comme je le disais au début de la vidéo
je vis, et je vis très bien grâce à Youtube aujourd'hui
et ça me permet de faire des trucs aussi ouf que ça
de rejoindre mon frère comme ça, sans devoir
m'y prendre 4 mois à l'avance, réfléchir, mettre de l'argent de côté, etc...
J'ai cette chance et j'en ai profité et vraiment merci du fond du coeur
parce que c'était un truc dont on se souviendra toujours !
Bah d'ailleurs on l'a marqué sur notre peau !
En se faisant tatoué un p*tain...euh, le même crabe, tous les deux
C'est inoubliable, c'est magique ce que j'ai vécu là-bas
en plus j'ai découvert l'Amérique du Sud qui était une destination que me faisait pas spécialement envie
et j'ai découvert une culture que je ne connaissais pas avant
et que j'ai adorée !
La seule déception c'était que quand j'ai dû partir
pour revenir sur Paris, faire des vidéos etc, mettre en ligne...
mon frère, à ce moment là, allait aux Caraïbes,
et vu qu'on s'aime énormément et qu'on adore se foutre le seum,
il m'envoyait des photos de lui aux Caraïbes
Et mec... p*tain, j'aurais tellement dû rester 2 jours de plus !
M*rde !
Mais c'est pas grave on s'est rattrapés plus tard
Et là c'est la rentrée scolaire, septembre octobre novembre...
Moi bizarrement, je me cale encore sur la rentrée scolaire
C'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je fais cette vidéo bilan
des 365 derniers jours à la moitié de l'année 2017
C'est pas logique ! Généralement les gens font ça fin 2017 !
Pour parler de l'année 2017
Mais moi je suis encore en année scolaire dans ma tête
J'suis un peu con...
Donc là septembre, octobre, novembre, on fait des vidéos essentiellement dans le studio
voire même que dans le studio je crois...
Sur des jeux vidéos, sur des quizzs, sur des jeux en ligne...
avec des potes, sur des jeux de société, j'en sais rien
mais ça m'amuse et en décembre j'me dis
"P*tain, en 2014 j'avais fait un Let's Play sur Alien Isolation
Les gens avaient adoré !
En 2015 j'ai fait un Let's Play sur Until Dawn et les gens avaient encore plus adoré
Cette année j'ai envie de faire un Let's Play, mais j'ai pas envie de le faire sur un jeu d'horreur
Et depuis quelques années, je suivais un petit peu, de plus ou moins près
La sortie de "The Last Guardian"
De Tricot ! P*tain...
Et j'ai peur parce que je me dis
"Bon, c'est un Let's Play... c'est un jeu qui a l'air hyper long...
c'est pas du tout un jeu d'horreur, y'a pas de... c'est pas mouvementé,
c'est pas du gameplay ouvert, c'est assez fermé, comme Until Dawn sauf que y'a pas le côté scénario
flippant d'Until Dawn
Mais je trouve que le jeu est d'une beauté exceptionnelle
que... ça va changer, justement, des 2 Let's Play que j'avais fait avant
et je me lance ! Je me lance, j'me dis "Allez, c'est parti !"
On le fait, au pire ça marche pas, c'est pas grave, mais...
j'ai trop envie de faire découvrir ce jeu aux gens et de leur faire ressentir
ces émotions que moi-même j'ai ressenti en y jouant"
Et puis surprise...
Gros carton !
Vous sur-kiffez "The Last Guardian" et ça m'a fait... Chaud au coeuuur !
De ouf !
Et ça rejoins ce que je vous disez toute à l'heure,
que j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire ce que je veux sur ma chaîne YouTube,
et il y aura la majorité des gens qui regarderont,
qui... qui... aimeront !
Enfin bref, merci pour ça c'était génial !
A l'heure actuelle, presque tous les épisodes ont passé la barre des 2 millions de vues,
ce qui est ENORME pour des vidéos comme ça !
Et même au-delà de ça,
je me suis vraiment rendu compte de l'impact que ce Let's Play avait eu
quand les gens qui me reconnaissaient dans la rue, que je voyais sur les conventions,
me disaient : "P*tain mec, the Last Guardian j'ai adoré !",
quand des potes de la vraie vie, plus vieux que moi, me disaient :
"P*tain, ma femme elle regarde tout le temps the Last Guardian,
elle suit ça comme une série !",
p*tain, ça me faisait super plaisir
et je me disais : "Ah ! Ca touche un peu un nouveau public,
mais ça plaît quand même à mon public actuel"
et ça c'est... c'est rare en fait !
Bref, l'expérience était géniale, du coup j'ai la pression parce que je me dis :
"Au prochain Let's Play, ça va être difficile de faire aussi bien voire mieux !",
mais on va essayer !
Le 18 décembre, je mets en ligne le dernier épisode du Let's Play sur the Last Guardian,
je pleure, parce que c'est la fin du jeu mais surtout parce que la fin du jeu elle est hyper triste,
et je décide de partir en Corée pendant 10 jours,
pays que j'avais déjà fait euh... au début de l'année en mars, quand j'étais allé au Japon,
j'avais fait un petit détour pendant 3 jours euh... en Corée,
et j'avais beaucoup aimé !
Donc je voulais y retourner et passer beaucoup plus de temps là-bas.
Les vacances, en tant que YouTubeur comme ça,
c'est pas des vacances à 100% parce que tu filmes,
et tu vas faire des montages le soir pour mettre en ligne tes 2 derniers jours passés en Corée,
'fin c'est... c'est très particulier mais... moi ça me convient,
dans le sens où je... j'arrive quand même
à profiter à fond de là où je suis,
tout en... en faisant profiter aussi les gens
euh... du cadre et des activités que je fais, donc c'est cool !
Là en Corée, je m'étais fait mon deuxième tatouage !
Par Hugo Tatoueur, un très très bon tatoueur,
qui est d'ailleurs passé sur Paris il y a pas longtemps dans un salon
pendant 10 jours et qui m'a fait un autre tatouage juste ici.
Voilà, c'était super marrant de le... de le revoir sur Paris,
alors que je l'avais vu en Corée la dernière fois qu'on s'était vus
c'est assez marrant !
J'avais tiré avec une arme à feu pour la première fois de ma vie,
j'avais mangé des poissons qui ressemblaient à des pénis,
j'avais été dans un bain public, pour la première fois,
nu, au milieu d'autres hommes nus !
ça ,c'est totalement un truc qui se fait énormément là-bas,
après une grosse journée de taf,
ils vont là-bas se détendre dans des eaux à 41-43°C,
ils sont biens, tout le monde est à poil, tout le monde s'en fout !
Puis, je termine mon séjour sur un nouvel an à Ongde,
le quartier que je vous avais montré même dans... dans... dans une ou plusieurs vidéos j'crois,
c'est mon quartier préféré, c'est un quartier très jeune, très hipster euh...
Et à Ongde, c'est là où il y a presque tous les tatoueurs,
c'est là où les jeunes sont assez décomplexés,
et même les vieux sont... le sont plus qu'ailleurs
et, j'suis à Ongde, entouré par un maximum de Coréens,
feu d'artifice, et j'me dis : "P*tain, je suis en train de vivre un nouvel an
dans un autre pays que le mien, j'suis en train de vivre ça en Corée !"
En plus, c'est des su... gros fêtards là-bas,
donc c'était vraiment grosse ambiance, c'était super !
Puis je rentre en France, hop hop hop on continue les p'tites vidéos gaming
diverses et variées...
Jusqu'au mois de février où... MamyTwink, que j'apprécie ENORMEMENT,
me PROPOSE de faire une exploration nocturne avec lui
dans un lieu en plus... qui m'attirait beaucoup...
les catacombes interdites de Paris !
C'était une nuit euh.. inoubliable, c'était vraiment une ambiance particulière,
c'était à la fois effrayant mais à la fois excitant
et... et... et cool en fait !
Ca s'est super bien passé et à un moment,
on est restés dans les catacombes pendant vraiment plusieurs heures
et à un moment je me souviens, on était posés dans un p'tit...
un mini-tunnel, vraiment où... on devait être un peu baissés comme ça, assis,
et on a discuté pendant des dizaines de minutes,
sans se rendre compte qu'on était dans l'endroit le moins euh... confortable du monde en fait !
Putain t'es coupé du monde, t'es dans ta bulle,
et... et on s'est arrêtés en plein milieu de l'exploration nocturne pour discuter,
MamyTwink a pris une p'tite photo.
J'suis d'ailleurs reparti plus tard avec MamyTwink faire de l'urbex dans un hôpital abandonné,
c'était très sympa !
Beaucoup plus horrifique que les catacombes !
Mais ça s'est bien passé, et... putain c'est toujours un plaisir MamyTwink,
c'est... c'est... il est adorable !
Un peu plus tard, le même mois, je fais...
j'ai encore du mal à réaliser ce que j'ai fait ce jour là tellement c'est dingue !
Euuuh... je visite l'Agence Spatiale Européenne, en Allemagne, à Cologne !
Grâce à mon influence, et donc grâce à vous, encore une fois,
j'ai... en fait j'ai... j'en ai jamais parlé,
j'ai des passions un peu dont je parle pas dans mes vidéos,
et l'espace en fait partie !
J'ai toujours été fasciné par le fait qu'on soit des petits grains de sable dans l'univers,
qu'on soit rien, que notre planète est un grain de sable,
je trouve ça incroyable !
A l'occasion, j'amène avec moi un ami qui s'appelle Abdel,
un ami du collège et lycée euh... et qui lui était encore en études,
et je lui dis euh, il est photographe donc je me dis "Bon, il pourra me cadrer, ça fera le job" !
Et pourquoi je le choisis lui ?
Parce que c'est un mec qu'est encore plus passionné que moi par l'espace !
Du coup, on y va ensemble en train,
on passe la journée là-bas, 2 jours même, c'était tous les 2,
on fait des débriefs le soir,
on pose 10 000 questions sur place, on était vraiment à fond,
et il a pu écrire un mémoire sur ça d'ailleurs !
Grâce à... à... vous du coup ! *Rires*
Vous l'avez mis bien cousins, putain !
Le 6 mars, c'est le lancement de la webTV "LeStream",
putain, ça faisait des années avec Micka, avec Cyprien,
on lance enfin le truc !
C'était beaucoup de taf, c'était épuisant
Mais maintenant c'est là, lestream.fr, c'est là et...
j'interviens des fois dans des émissions, on s'éclate,
que ce soit sur les primes, ou des émissions sur le gaming,
ou juste les croiser dans les bureaux, ça me fait plaisir !
Je suis super content de ce projet,
mais après le lancement j'étais fatigué !
Et quand t'es fatigué tu fais quoi ?
Tu prends des vacances hein !
Et bah là c'est juste le... le meilleur souvenir de... de ma life que j'ai fait !
J'ai pu payer un voyage de 2 semaines au Japon à mon frère et à mon père,
on est partis entre Hauchard !
Ca faisait 30 ans que je disais à mon frère que je voulais l'emmener au Japon !
Et c'est un truc qui s'est fait grâce à l'argent que génère ma chaîne YouTube, clairement !
Donc grâce à vous qui regardez les vidéos et qui générez cet argent !
J'ai pu offrir le plus beau cadeau que je pouvais offrir à ma famille,
c'est-à-dire des souvenirs !
C'est quelque chose, toute notre vie on s'en souviendra,
même quand je les vois à l'heure actuelle,
on ressort des anecdotes du Japon,
et... je sais que ça les a marqué, ça m'a marqué aussi !
On a dormi dans une caravane le plus proche du mont Fuji,
on a vu un lever de soleil MAGNIFIQUE au-dessus de ce dernier,
on s'est baignés dans des sources chaudes naturelles à Hakone,
on a dormi dans un hôtel traditionnel japonais,
ce qu'on appelle un Ryokan,
on a pu fabriquer nos propres nouilles,
les mêmes qu'on se faisait des années plus tôt le midi au lycée quand on avait 2 heures pour manger,
on a visité plein de monuments, des temples et des temples, on en a bouffé
on est allés dans un petit café à chat, bon !
*Miaulement*
On a joué des heures et des heures à Tekken dans une salle arcade,
j'suis allé chez le coiffeur me teindre les cheveux en violet...
... nan ça on s'en bat les couilles !
Ah oui, un autre truc important aussi et que j'adore avec YouTube,
c'est que ça crée des amitiés !
Tu rencontres des gens géniaux, comme par exemple récemment McFly & Carlito
avec qui on a fait plusieurs vidéos ensemble.
Mais à l'époque, juste avant de partir au Japon j'ai rencontré Maxenss,
euh... qui est un très bon ami à Seb et euh je voyais Seb et Maxenss était là.
Et à l'heure actuelle, c'est devenu un très bon ami,
on a fait cette vidéo de merde là, où on doit faire du bruit pour faire avancer un perso, le faire sauter !
Pourquoi je souligne ça dans cette vidéo ?
C'est parce que depuis en fait, je.. on se parle énormément avec Maxenss,
on bosse sur plusieurs trucs,
et en fait ça me permet de... de... d'avoir un petit peu de changement dans ce que je fais au quotidien,
de bosser sur des trucs un peu plus gros, annexes, avec son aide, de bosser à 2
'fin, c'est un truc que j'fais pas habituellement,
moi, mes vidéos c'est que de l'improvisation où je suis généralement seul devant mon ordi,
et ça me fait du bien d'avoir ça à côté de manière régulière,
donc euh merci Maxenss !
A mon retour du Japon le 7 avril,
je mets en ligne la Overwatch Rap Battle !
Le projet qui a pris, putain, des mois et des mois de... de travail.
C'est le plus gros projet vidéo que j'ai fait sur ma chaîne YouTube à l'heure actuelle,
franchement j'en suis très fier !
Et l'expérience que... que ça m'a apportée, c'est... c'est dingue !
C'est 110 niveaux d'un coup dans World of Warcraft, vraiment !
Mais bon au final, même si je pouvais plus écouter le son parce que je l'avais déjà écouté 800 000 fois
et le clip, pareil, j'avais eu 600 versions avant la version finale,
donc je pouvais plus blérer cette vidéo avant même de la mettre en ligne, c'est génial !
Au final, je la mets en ligne,
des premiers retours assez négatifs, les gens étaient un peu déçus,
j'étais triste, je me disais : "Putain, merde, je me suis donné les moyens de faire ce truc,
tout le monde m'a aidé, tout le monde a été cool avec moi,
tout le monde m'a soutenu et... MERDE CA PLAÎT PAS PUTAIN !"
Et en fait, c'est comme..., j'ai remarqué que généralement, quand un Youtubeur sort une chanson sur YouTube,
les premiers retours sont assez négatifs,
et puis après euh... ça se tasse, ça va, les retours positifs sont là,
de manière régulière, il y a plus aucun retour négatif,
c'est assez bizarre !
Au final, en 3 mois, la vidéo a fait 15 millions de vues,
c'est la... l'une des vidéos les plus vues de ma chaîne YouTube,
Blizzard l'a même mis dans leur launcher euh Battlenet aux US
donc il y a des anglais qui se ramenaient sur la vidéo et qui disaient :
"Putain, c'est en français, il casse les couilles, je quitte !"
♫ Merci les anglophones ! ♫
J'ai même vu des mecs se clasher avec des anglais dans les commentaires
en disant : "Mec, la vidéo elle est en français mais il y a des sous-titres anglais
euh nous euh, les 9 dixièmes des trucs qu'on regarde c'est en anglais, il y a les sous-titres en français,
on casse pas les couilles !"
Poooooooo !!!
En fait vous êtes des thugs ! Putain, starfoullah l'agression ! *Rires*
Et le mois suivant, en avril, je vis le truc le plus ouf de toute ma vie, je fais un vol en 0 G !
C'est la suite de la vidéo à l'Agence Spatiale Européenne,
je fais un vol en 0 G et... putain, c'était l'expérience la plus folle de ma vie ! Hein ! Comme le titre l'indique !
C'est terrible parce qu'à l'heure actuelle, je... je... je me souviens déjà plus de ce que ça fait d'être en... en... en 0 G,
je me souviens plus ! Mon cerveau a oublié !
Je me suis de nouveau complètement habitué à la gravité, j'ai même plus conscience qu'il y a de la gravité, tout comme vous,
mais je sais, que sur le coup, j'étais... bouche bée,
et j'me disais : "Putain,  le paradis, ça doit être... ça doit être un truc comme ça !"
Et 2 mois plus tard, on en est à aujourd'hui,
euh... il y a 2 gros projets dans les cartons,
dont l'un des 2 qui sort peut-être euh la semaine prochaine, en fin de semaine prochaine
ou celle d'après mais j'espère en fin de semaine prochaine !
Et l'autre qui sortira beaucoup plus tard et qui ne sera pas un projet YouTube
mais qui est très cool et... Maxenss m'aide dessus d'ailleurs
et c'est super ! C'est un truc au long terme qui permet de faire autre chose que du YouTube et qui te fait kiffer !
Enfin bref !
On a fait le tour de cette rétrospective sur ces 365 derniers jours
qui étaient les plus forts de... de... de ces 6 dernières années sur YouTube pour moi !
Merci !
Je pense que la meilleure des conclusions c'est juste de dire merci.
J'suis hyper ému de...
de voir à quel point vous pouvez euh... soutenir quelqu'un sans même le connaître personnellement en fait !
Je vous remercie pour tout ce que vous avez fait pour moi,
pour tout ce que vous m'avez permis d'offrir euh... à des gens et... même à ma famille !
Hein ! A mon frère, à mon père, à ma mère, à ma grand-mère !
Alors attention ! Je suis pas parfait du tout hein ! *Rires*
On dirait dans cette vidéo, tout est beau, tout est rose,
je suis pas du tout parfait, j'ai mes défauts comme tout le monde !
Et même des fois sur YouTube j'ai fait de la merde, j'ai dit des trucs cons euh...
Ca arrive à tout le monde de... de faire des erreurs
mais euh... euh... vous m'avez toujours, même malgré mes erreurs, soutenu
et... et... suivi et... j'trouve ça dingue !
Donc, je vous remercie !
J'essaie de rester humain et moi-même hein !
Les gens adorent dire cette phrase ! "Eh, surtout change pas, reste comme ça frère" (voix de racaille)
Ou alors, ah oui non, la meilleure c'est : "Eh, franchement, t'arrête pas, t'arrête pas" (voix de racaille) *Rires*
C'est trop mignon comme phrase mais moi quand on me dit ça, je me dis juste :
"Mais... j'ai jamais parlé d'arrêter, mais non, je vais pas arrêter ! Pourquoi tu veux que j'arrête ? Non !"
C'est génial !
Bah voilà, j'ai dit tout ce que j'avais à dire !
Putain je me suis vidé, ça m'fait du bien !
Je me suis vidé là, j'avais trop besoin, ça fait très longtemps en fait que je veux faire cette vidéo !
Bah 2 mois en fait ! Juste après le vol 0 G je voulais la faire
et... putain, ça fait du bien quand ça sort, ça fait du bien de revenir sur tout ça,
de... de se rendre compte qu'on a avancé, qu'on a fait des trucs vraiment cools c'te année !
Et puis, j'espère que cette année je revivrai des trucs aussi riches et intenses !
En tout cas, je vais tout faire pour !
J'espère que la grosse vidéo qui sort la semaine prochaine ou la semaine d'après va vous plaire,
et puis je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo !
On va finir sur un truc euh très simple euh même si je l'ai déjà dit...
Merci beaucoup !